voici comment la police de hong kong
procède pour les arrestations
ici au domicile de la politicienne
clarisse jung présidente d'un des
conseils de district de l'ancienne
colonie britannique
les policiers lui présente son mandat
d'arrêt en vertu de la nouvelle loi sur
la sécurité nationale un texte
drastiques imposées par pékin
la police de hong kong confirment les
arrestations pour subversion à la suite
d'une vaste opération matinale qui a
mobilisé un millier d'agents
[Musique]
on les accuse de vouloir utiliser leur
siège au conseil législatif pour
s'opposer au budget et forcé l'arrêt des
opérations du gouvernement de hong kong
le président du parti démocrate
loki neil réplique que le gouvernement
refuse d'écouter les hongkongais et
préfère se venger oui aux ateliers
ce n'est pas notre plan qui pousse en
gang au bord de l'abyme mais plutôt le
pouvoir politique qui refuse lâchement
ce qui nous a été promis en 1997 par la
loi fondamentale
c'est la fin de la démocratie en com et
maintenant toute opposition politique
pourra être jugée comme une sanction et
est passé en prison à vie
parmi les personnalités d'opposition les
plus connus joshua wang qui milite pour
l'autodétermination ici en compagnie
d'une kinois y leicester shum et prins
wang il a déjà été arrêté plusieurs fois
et condamné et privés de droits
politiques ici avec ivan l'âme en route
vers la prison l'avocat américain john
clancy a également été arrêté et la
police a perquisitionné le cabinet pour
lequel il travaille et qui a été engagé
pour défendre les droits de la personne
en kong
c'est le premier américain interpellé au
nom de la nouvelle loi ce qui va
compliquer davantage les relations entre
la chine et les états unis
le prochain secrétaire d'état américain
anthony blinken a réagi
les arrestations sont une attaque contre
ceux qui défendent les droits universels
et l'administration baydan harris se
tiendra aux côtés du peuple de hong kong
et contre la répression de la démocratie
par pékin au canada le ministre françois
philippe champagne appelle aussi à leur
libération
ils dénoncent la répression du
pluralisme politique
le mépris de la loi fondamentale d' un
pays deux systèmes
de son côté pékin fait le parallèle
entre les violences du capitole
américains et celle des manifestations
de hong kong en 2019 au yard
à hong kong il n'y a pas eu de morts au
moins dit la porte parole des affaires
étrangères
mais les médias américains ont alors
décrit les émeutiers comme des héros de
la démocratie des réactions différentes
qui dit elle mérite une réflexion
sérieuse et profonde
jean michel leprince sera du canada à
montréal